but I heard one time that you were on
like I guess theater you were doing
theater and you fell asleep on stage
like your character is supposed to be
asleep but you actually fell asleep yes
I fancy myself a very professional actor
do you but apparently that's not true uh
no I was uh one of my very first jobs
was uh in a Broadway show called
Brighton Beach Memoirs wonderful Neil
Simon play and and amazing amazing
writer um and uh the the my character uh
had to fall asleep at one point uh he
had to go upstairs and go to sleep in
his room uh uh but you have not
experienced Terror Until you realize
that you fell asleep during the Broadway
show you're starring in um oh my
goodness uh and I because I remember
there was an actor named Joe Breen who
wonderful actor who who was in um he was
in Galaxy Quest what and he uh and I and
I remember just laying there and he was
sleeping across he was sleeping across
from me but he is a better actor who who
who fakes it apparently um and uh and I
remember him and I remember just the
look on his face going John John John
and his eyes got all huge uh and and
then I was like huh I wonder what's I
wonder what Joe's uh what his problem is
exactly and then and then the adrenaline
shot of all time went through my body um
because I realized I was uh I had fallen
asleep during the play that I was
supposed to um but thankfully uh if you
were curse enough it's muscle memory so
so I I leapt in and the monologue that I
had to say thankfully leapt into my
mouth but that when you had a nap you
should have felt fresh you're right
should have felt real fresh there's
nothing more terrifying cuz I grew up a
musical theater being on stage and going
why is everyone quiet yes and they're
and they're quiet because it's your turn
to say something yep yeah yep exactly
that's when I knew the the was not for
me um but anyway but I heard that were
you fir fired from that play and was it
because you fell asleep no interestingly
I was fired before I fell asleep um so
that's yeah no no I I was actually
Matthew brc's understudy for a long time
uh well not for that long because they
they fired me um but uh but no it was
that was my first first gig uh I was
like I was 18 and I was terrified and
Matthew is a wonderful wonderful
performer he was he was the lead in the
show it was his breakout role he won the
Tony for it yeah uh and uh so I was I
was terrified uh and they they fired me
right after he won the Tony uh I think
because they wanted some they wanted
somebody that people had heard of in the
show taking over for him as opposed to
me um yeah but uh but it was it was a
very formative experience in my life
because all of my my parent my parents
are performers and and uh and all of
their actors friends really gathered
around me because this is the kind of
thing this happens to actors all the
time uh uh and and and how you react to
it really uh one shows who you are yeah
yeah and and and I did the the most
constructive thing which was to vow
Revenge um and you know what though
sometimes that's feel for your fire it
it was actually I I did not see like why
you should have picked me
[Music]
exactly
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home